so what I wanted to do here is have a
discussion about how the Green Lantern
ring works then what I'm hoping is that
at the end of this video you'll have a
solid understanding of how it originated
as well as how its function has changed
over the course of the years
so while there have been various
individuals who have found themselves in
possession of a Green Lantern ring over
the course of DC's continuity including
Kyle Rayner Guy Gardner John Stewart and
Hal Jordan the story of the Green
Lantern ring can actually be traced back
to all-american comics issue number 16
in 1940 with the introduction of Alan
Scott as part of DC's Golden Age
superhero lineup following the success
of Superman Alan Scott is the original
Green Lantern and was created by mark
knodell alongside Bill Finger and with
heroes still being a proven of concept
at the time the powers of Alan Scott
would largely confined to the realm of
magic as the origin was initially
presented to us at some point in the
history of China a meteor crashed on
earth after breaking open the metal
inside burst into a green flame with a
disembodied voice announcing that the
fire would reignite three times first to
bring death then to bring life and
finally to bring power again because
these were early superhero stories
there's not much here in the way of
quality content but what we're told is
that once the flames extinguished one of
the onlookers named Chang used the
liquid metal inside the meteor which
existed as the source of the flames to
create a green lamp believing that this
would bring down the wrath of the gods
and because Chang was known to have
dabbled in books involving sorcery the
rest of the community killed Chang
erupting into flames the lamp seemed to
kill everyone in the community in turn
stating that the flame of death had been
satisfied the following this the lamp
came into the possession of multiple
people over the years and while under
the control of those with an evil heart
the lamp brought destruction but for
those who had pure hearts the lamp
brought fortune at some point along its
history the lamp fell into the hands of
guards at an insane asylum considering
it to be an object of irrelevance they
guard simply handed it over to an
occupant named Billings who is actually
an insane person himself but had a
pension for creating modern lanterns
using various materials after remodeling
the lamp into a more modern design the
flames erupted a second time to restore
sanity to Billings provided with the
opportunity to start over billing simply
leaves the asylum and the lantern
declares that the flames of life have
been satisfied in transitioning to the
origin of Allen Scott we find that the
government had chosen to hire Allen's
company to construct a bridge rather
than his competitor
company run by a man named Dekker is
seeking to take his revenge and
discredit Allen Dekker sabotages the
bridge resulting in a train crash
finding himself to be the sole survivor
Allen comes upon the lantern and when
the flames erupted for Thor time Allen
is told that the flame of power will
bestow upon him the ability to seek out
and destroy evil the fashioning a ring
to Hollis its power Allen's told that in
order to maintain his abilities he will
need to focus his willpower as well as
ensure that the ring makes contact with
the lantern once every 24 hours
following this Allen Scott seeks out
Decker to hold him accountable for his
actions and along the way provides us
with a demonstration of his abilities in
addition to the power of flight Allen
Scott can move objects as well as phase
through solid matter and even withstand
injury from all forms of metal and so
after defeating several henchmen and
handing Decker over to the police force
criminal acts Allen Scott adopts the
moniker of the Green Lantern now as a
comic book industry grew and saw the
arrival of more heroes the powers of the
Green Lantern ring were expanded to
allow for greater feats in order to keep
up with the changing times but the
element of magic as the source of the
Rings power had always remained a
mainstay where all American comics
issued number 21 would demonstrate the
Green Lantern rings ability to hold a
falling vehicle in place the actual
introduction of a hard light construct
which is to say a tangible object
originating from the ring didn't
actually appear until issue number 24
when Allen Scott uses the light from his
reign to physically cut through the nose
of an airplane however while it is
debated as to whether this is a hard
light construct I would like you to keep
this in the back of your head because
this will be the foundation for the
powers set as is provided in future
stories now as you discussed in previous
videos because of world war ii saw the
cancellation of several comic book
publications one of which was the Green
Lantern however were the 1950s and 1960s
saw a re-emergence of heroes in pop
culture DC took the opportunity to
return the Green Lantern to their
superhero landscape removing Allen Scott
and all previously existing continuity
regarding the function of the Lantern
ring DC instead chose to introduce Hal
Jordan and place of Allen Scott and
modify the basis for the Lantern Rings
power with technology rather than magic
as this explained to us the source of
power for the Green Lantern ring is the
central battery core
constructed by the guardians of the
universe as the basis for the Green
Lantern Corps operating as a police
force the central battery core collects
the willpower of all sentient beings in
the universe by harnessing their own
will the members of the Green Lantern
Corps can amplify this power and in turn
achieve incredible feats using their
imagination now in the early stories of
Hal Jordan as a new Green Lantern these
demonstrations included many of the feat
seen in Alan Scott's comics including
flight and the requirement of Hal Jordan
to recharge his ring but these stories
also included the ability of Hal Jordan
to create giant fists boxes or objects
that were composed of hard light and
could be used to entrap criminals or
shield himself from attacks in addition
to this the inherent weakness of the
Green Lantern rings power was the color
yellow now in these early stories the
explanation offered by DC which of the
Green Lantern rings had no effect on the
color yellow and by extension allowed
for the introduction of Sinestro and his
yellow Lantern ring and so while this
remained the accepted standard for a
large majority of DC's publication
history with the Green Lantern rebirth
event in 2005 Geoff Johns completely
retooled the Green Lantern mythology
maintaining some of Hal Jordans history
and stating at the Green Lanterns derive
their power from the central battery
core and the willpower of the universe
Geoff Johns actually took the concept of
parallax and reimagined it with my
thanks going out to comics story and for
clarification what we know is that were
previously how Jordan simply declared
himself to be parallax prior to his
perceived death this declaration was a
name only in order to highlight the fact
that he was the opposite of the hero
that he had been before
under Geoff Johns parallax was turned
into an actual entity establishing that
parallax is the embodiment of fear
itself the guardians of the universe
locked the entity away and the central
battery core because parallax was yellow
and represented the very essence of fear
and because fear is the opposite of
willpower geoff johns used this as a red
khan to establish why the Green
Lantern's were unable to affect the
color yellow now in addition to this wet
Khan under the Green Lantern rebirth
event and his subsequent stories the
Green Lantern's of willpower and
sinestro's yellow lanterns of fear were
met with the red lanterns of Rage the
blue lanterns of Hope the black lanterns
of death the white lanterns of life the
orange lanterns of greed the indigo
lanterns of compassion and the star
sapphires of love in addition to this
each of these Lantern cores are able to
affect the powers of the others and a
sort of checks and balances where the
yellow lantern ring of fear requires a
Green Lantern wielder to succumb to
their own fear in order to be affected
the blue indigo and red lantern rings
affect the Green Lantern ring in a
similar fashion the blue answered ring
of Hope boosts the abilities of a Green
Lantern ring and in turn the Green
Lantern ring actually allows the Blue
Lantern ring to work to its full
potential and so in effect they're
basically feeding off of one another the
indigo Lantern ring of compassion has
the ability to copy the powers of other
Lantern rings and by extension their
powers can be absorbed by the Green
Lantern's now while the indigo and the
Blue Lantern rings can impact the Green
Lantern ring for good the Red Lantern
ring impacts for evil as the ring of
Rage the Red Lantern ring has actually
seen a bit of an adjustment since its
initial introduction originally the Red
Lantern ring was able to corrupt and
deep power a Green Lantern ring
regardless of the circumstance but in
order to ensure that checks and balances
remained
Jeff John's effectively established that
like the relationship between yellow
lanterns and fear the red lantern rings
can only impact a Green Lantern ring if
the Green Lantern gives in to their rage
with that being said we're going to
bring this video to an end I hope it
made sense to you guys if it did let me
know and I will catch you guys later
peace